[Music]
with the release of the childsplay
remake just around the corner we have
slowly started to see promotional
material filter its way onto the web in
the past couple of months today sees the
online release of the film's teaser
trailer after was initially only shown
at the star of the new are a film
prodigy throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the trailer as well as
what it implies there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything about the movie just yet
and I highly suggest that you turn off
now but with that out the way I'm
definition and welcome to the channel
where I watch it so you don't have to
the trailer opens with a minute long
commercial from the caslen corporation
in it CEO and founder Henrique Aslan
discusses how the company specializes in
building revolutionary products for the
betterment of mankind the trailer then
segways off into how the corporation
have developed the most interactive toy
of all time named body this pretty much
confirms the majority of rumors that
have circulated around the film for the
past year or so we now know for definite
that the voodoo curse has been
completely dropped and instead buddy
will be like an Alexa on steroids that
once revenge for every time you told
this shut up whilst this portion of the
trailer was leaked earlier in the week
there are some additional scenes in the
full release that take a more darker
turn from here we see Andy Barclay
unwrapping a buddy dollar has been given
to him by his mother Karen played by
Aubrey Plaza the words best friend
repeat in the background like a broken
record to let you know that there's a
glitch in the doll somewhere and things
are going to take a more sinister turn
whilst we don't actually get a glimpse
of buddy or Chucky as you'll probably be
called beyond a silhouette we do see
that the devilish doll hasn't lost its
taste for murder we get flashes of a
body covered in a sheet a person falling
onto a car a car crashing and a glimpse
that Detective Mike Norris played by
Brian Tyree Henry the phrase friends
till the end flashes on screen - and we
get a shot of Karen with tape over her
mouth before it ends on the ominous
flash of the doll in darkness so what
can we take from this trailer well it's
very clear that the film is
indeed going against the better
judgement of fans are making a terminate
a toy that goes rogue with its AI we
also know from information on the
website that the doll is capable of
possessing other buddies and also seeing
through their line of sight
thus hiding from them will be very
difficult if the film does seem to be
very much following the pattern of the
first film with the doll being
discovered and then going homicidal and
it's sort of bearing away from the more
extreme versions of the character that
we got later down the line in the
franchise ban reaction has been mixed to
the trailer thus far with most staying
that they are waiting until the sci-fi
show drops instead but this definitely
did pique my interest
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the trailer and what you took from it
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of the Avengers and game super
bowl trailer which will be linked at the
end this is the channel for people who
were mad into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you